foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong a podcast By Rotten Tomatoes and
for the very first time in the Rotten
Tomatoes Studio we are all here together
I am Mark Ellis that is Jacqueline Coley
Jacqueline we did it we made it to a
studio only 120 episodes into the show
it is really strange because what I want
to tell people is this is what we used
to do like back when there was a world
it was always here I did not have to be
an audio engineer I did not have to know
about what what settings we had on the
Motu I missed these days I'm so excited
and excited that we have our girl back
Mr Danny this is Danny Fernandez here I
am very special guest uh actress
producer writers uh for everything from
Netflix to Amazon shows and uh author
written comic books you work with DC you
really have done it all but it feels
like this is your season Danny oh thank
you oh Halloween I thought you just
meant like I was winning literally threw
me off y'all for those that are just
listening to this Danny has really come
with the holidays Halloween spirit as
she looks like Beetlejuice so I really
wanted to say Mr Beetlejuice well as far
as the costuming yeah yeah you don't
actually represent Beetlejuice like it's
not like she like went makeup no no but
it's very like she's gonna go full
Keaton I would call it Disney bounding
100 something yeah
low key cosplay yeah but you look very
fall as well I think we're all doing a
lot of fall although Danny did say that
you were a little bit too spring but
honestly I could see this at a Friday
Night Lights football game I really
that's true that's true that's what
Danny is here to do she's here to take
my ego when it starts soaring and I get
a little Icarus she's the son and she
just melts that wax and just gets me
right back down to earth I feel like I'm
sort of like a prequel this is like the
Jeepers Creeper scarecrow when he was
still alive and you know going to high
school meeting women before the the bad
stuff started happening I absolutely
agree with that I'm also glad to be back
I know I've had like a sporadic bit of a
tendons but I was at the Middleburg
Festival last week I know I haven't been
on the podcast a lot like I know let's
go stress the elf in the room I've been
traveling what a nice glossing over a
sporadic attendance record of late of
late Bueller Bueller nine times
Jacqueline's been all over the world
Festival uh this past weekend I met a
really uh great fan at the Middleburg
Film Festival he's on my Instagram and
he was super sweet and I told him that I
got to come back to the episode today
and tell him like you know guess what
like I met a fan in person and you
weren't there but you were you were
doing your own travel system I was in
San Diego at the wonderful La Jolla
Comedy Store this past weekend a lot of
fans a lot of RT is wrong fans because
really well you can tell when they're a
fan of the show because that's the they
don't come up to you and say hey thanks
for a great show what can I get a
picture of their first thing is they'll
just name a movie oh my gosh and then
they just want to go right into what the
Tomato Meter is and particular this time
of year a lot of horror movies that are
getting too high or too low for a
particular fans taste on the Tomato
Meter so it's a really fun episode of
the scariest movies of all time that
we're doing today but this is a
different list than you might be
expecting when you tune into the show
because this is not strictly by Tomato
Meter so we have a top 10 here and how
we got the top 10 Danielle is a fan poll
that we did back in 2020 so it was this
massive Outreach that we did we wanted
everybody to participate via the website
rottentomatoes.com and social media we
did all of our partner sites across all
these platforms and so now we have the
top 10 fan voted lists from 2020. let's
get into this thing number one is the
Exorcist
all time still from 1973 The Exorcist
number two is hereditary number three is
The Conjuring number four is The Shining
number five is the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre that's the original from 74.
number six is the ring the American
version from 2002. number seven is
Halloween you know which Halloween it is
EOG the original number eight is
Sinister nine Insidious and number ten
is it yeah from
2017 I asked the question to Our Guest
first Danny Fernandez is Rotten Tomatoes
or in this case the Rotten Tomatoes fan
pull yeah wrong about the scariest
movies of all time I have to say the
Rotten Tomatoes fan poll is wrong about
the scariest movies of all time I heard
a lot of iconic horror movies on there
and I want to say there's a difference
legendary iconic horror the best horror
movies of all time is different than the
scariest movie of all time I just want
to say that I completely agree and as
the writer that she is
matter no I I agree although I will say
of this list I've seen everything on it
except for I've not watched number one
all the way through so I do think that
is indicative of it and I do think the
exercise oh the exercise because you
were too scared I just feel like that's
not a place for me to go I had enough
fear of religion growing up and I don't
need an entire film to let me know that
religious is some scary you know and the
one thing I will say about The Exorcist
too is I've watched tons of like
um film essays on it I know everything
that happened I've seen clips from it
but just the idea of immersing myself
and giving myself over to that film I
can't I can't do it that's fair that's a
fair play I think that we all had an
infusion of of religious Dogma somewhere
in our careers growing up and I think a
lot of people are like that whether it's
Catholicism or something else but the
Exorcist it can just get in your bones
in a different way than anything else on
this list for me anyway there are some
movies that I see here that I'm like
okay it's a good movie it's a scary
movie but how did it get in over this
yeah so we're gonna talk about all the
these things we all think that the list
is wrong somewhat and so we're just
going to reconfigure our list but before
we get into our take on this and we get
deep into the movie talk with the
spookiest movies of all time let's turn
it over to our buddy Tim Ryan he's our
expert review curation manager here he
kind of compiles all of the reviews and
he's going to tell us what the critics
were saying at the time of I guess some
of these releases Tim Ryan it's you only
get two minutes that's a segment two
minutes with Tim it's gonna be a
mouthful
[Music]
way back in 2020 we had Rotten Tomatoes
asked our users what are their picks for
the scariest movies of all time before I
start I just want to know these are not
the best reviewed horror movies of all
time though a few of them are in the
running for that title as well so here
it is the top 10 scariest movies as
selected by RT users number one is the
Exorcist from 1973 which is certified
fresh at 84 on the Tomato Meter with 86
reviews and it has an 87 audience score
number two is hereditary from 2018 which
is certified fresh at 90 with 300 183
reviews and it has a 69 audience score
number three is The Conjuring from 2013
which is certified fresh at 86 percent
with 226 reviews and it has an 83
audience score number four is The
Shining from 1980 which is certified
fresh at 82 with 101 reviews and it has
a 93 audience score number five is the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre from 1974 which
is certified fresh at 88 with 65 reviews
and it has an 82 audience score number
six is the ring from 2002 which is fresh
at 71 with 206 reviews though it has a
48 audience score number seven is
Halloween from 1978 which is certified
fresh at 96 with 81 reviews and it has
an 89 audience score number eight is
Sinister from 2012 which is fresh at 63
with 157 reviews and it has a 62
audience score number nine is Insidious
from 2010 which is fresh at 66 percent
with 176 reviews and it has a 62
audience score and finally at number 10
it from 2017 is certified fresh at 86
with 390 reviews and it has an 87
audience score so those are RT users
scariest movies happy Halloween trick or
treat back to you folks ah there we go
so we get the rundown again and uh I
feel like this is one of those lists
where we get to talk about the first
time that we saw a truly scary movie the
first movie that really stuck with us so
let's just go ahead and get into movie
talk right now
[Music]
okay so Danny first time you sat down
maybe you were by yourself maybe you're
with your family and you knew that you
were gonna watch something scary it
wasn't like oh this happened to be on TV
which was my intro Into The Exorcist by
the way it was just on TV one time and
we all sat down and watched it was it
like Showtime or HBO or something was it
like the full effect was it on network
TV like what what it must have been a
network TV this was back you had like
the the we had the little TV
88 in Northern California I didn't
remember it but but it wasn't scary to
me initially or or my siblings because
you're watching on like ABC it was
hilarious to us because there was this
girl who was our age who was throwing up
and her head was spinning and she was
saying bad words and we're like this is
our hero yeah this is this is the
rebellious nature that we that we feel
inside of ourselves if they can put
Scarface on network television and find
a way to like change all that they can
find in the 80s I think I would love to
see the edit yeah and I mean it's
probably like a half hour it didn't hold
up then three years later I saw it again
very different answer but I cut you off
Daniel what is your scary movie the
first time you sat down and you're
preparing yourself oh well those are two
different things so I just want to say
my first scary movie that I saw it was
one of those things where like my family
you know your family would get like HBO
for the weekend or something like they
would do some showtime
and so and so for my brothers and I we
watched House on Haunted Hill the Remake
it's still messed up oh it is messed up
there's somebody being cut open there's
like we it was like weird experiments in
this insane asylum and so we were
watching that as little kids which we
should not have been watching terrified
me and a very excited cast in that movie
yes I remember that cast too that was
that was an interesting one there's a
ton of things on here that I would like
go one or the other but I can definitely
think of like auditions not on here like
audition the scary movies oh I didn't
think that that I didn't think that
House on Haunted Hill was the scariest
it was just my first scary movie
yeah what was your gateway drug my well
I didn't watch them for forever so the
first movie that I can actually remember
buying a ticket to that was a scary
movie was The Grudge and I was forced to
go see it with that boy oh you went on a
date to see the garage he made me go see
The Grudge and I was like um we are done
like I was like I really feel like and
this poor guy he probably didn't know
what he was getting into but probably
didn't I I I'm all for you mean you meet
a nice young lady young man whatever the
case may be you want to go on a date I
think a scary movie is I think it's a
good day first date but the Grudge in
particular not so much because let's say
things are things are working things are
flowing and you're gonna make out after
the movie right let's say it's happening
The Grudge is the worst one to see
because that's the one where the kid's
mouth it just keeps opening and so if
you're going in for a kiss that's
probably still in your head a little bit
that they the mouth's gonna get I it
doesn't feel like it's a kissy kind of
movie it is a lot of like dragging like
yeah body coming after you like it's
almost better to have a jump scare movie
where you jump and then you want to go
to the person but it's not literally
like the this you know morbid little
being is like crawling out of the TV it
was such a disturbing movie I don't know
what that kid was thinking Terry if you
listen to this podcast hilarious email
in what was your first doctor says
speaking of uh crawling through the TV
one way or the other I think the people
probably listening or watching us at
home they heard the list the top 10 fan
voted lists from 2020 and they're like
well where's Poltergeist I think that's
a movie that you can that you could
safely say really was the the first
scary movie that an entire generation
saw growing up it came out that magical
year of 82 and it still scares the crap
out of me poltergeist Danny Fernandez
Poltergeist is one of my favorite movies
that's me but there's there's horror
movies that are popcorn movies and
Poltergeist is a popcorn movie for me
it's like something that you can safely
like comfortably you know it doesn't
have a lot of like body Gore what why
are you laughing I would never think of
poltergeist as a comfort movie but if
you're a horror fan that means you could
you've seen every horror movie you can
take on a lot of horror there are things
that are incredibly unsettling that like
I literally want to vomit and
Poltergeist is not one it's just like
action it's like a fun like scary you
know the clown my one of my what am I
still gets me as a yes the tree still
gets as someone that is making TV and
film now one of my favorite the pr that
they practically shot was a scene in the
kitchen with the chairs and so that they
practically did where you see the camera
trick of they they turn and then they
had glued I believe all those chairs
together and set them there you know and
it's so I love anything I love that a
lot of filmmakers are going back to
practical effects I just think there's
something very tangible that's like
super creepy about it um so I love
Poltergeist I don't think it's this
because I want to know what's the scary
movie that y'all didn't hear in the top
10 that you think needs to be in the top
ten so we're all going to take a movie
out okay this is like your fantasy
football roster you can't just keep
putting movies in the top 10. you want
to put something in you got to take
something out I'm gonna kick this off
with a movie that I think if we're just
going scariest okay because you made a
great point up top Danny it's not
necessarily the movie that has the best
Tomato Meter rating or or the most
iconic horror movie it's the one that
scares the crap out of you the most it
never did that for me same I think we
saw it together we did yeah because that
was still back in this studio there was
a different show
well especially because Jack under the
time because I think she had just found
out that Bill Hader been casting it
chapter two all right so Jack was in
there the whole time just watching this
prequel for her future boyfriend to be
in the sequel husband but thank you I
thought you were gonna say I thought
when you started to say you were like
that's back when I was with and I'm like
man Jacqueline just marks all of her
movies by who she's dating I mean
honestly no no but that's back when we
were doing a different show we were
doing it for it I remember that and that
was like early days me and Mark uh
seeing screenings not quite friends yet
but definitely knew who he was and I was
not scared by that one because I
remember we actually had to do a Rotten
Tomatoes like trip to the movies because
at that time I remember telling them I
don't want to go
we had to get a school bus it was
literally the entire Rotten Tomatoes
signed permission slips but that was
like the last movie that I ever even
felt trepidation I agree I would kick
that one out too okay so it is at number
10 and it's 86 certified fresh I think
we can all agree it's a very enjoyable
movie and and I love the opening
sequence of this that's terrifying one
of the best openings in horror history
yes
Georgie
[Music]
but then you're just more rude about the
kids against the bullies and then
Pennywise kind of shows up and I also
had to turn into a parent after
screening that movie because my dear
friend Josh makuga was sitting next to
me at the screening and he is the he's
the wimpiest person I've ever seen
walking into it his his face was in my
armpit the whole movie so I couldn't
really be scared I had to put on a
strong face for him I'm taking it out
and the movie I'm putting in it might
sound a little odd and we know that I'm
a fan of Threes on this show I will
return to the Jedi I love night rain Elm
Street three I'm putting in Paranormal
Activity three oh that's so great that's
great it's the best of all of them
because that's the one you talk about
the cool camera triple effects yes in
Poltergeist yeah they had a lodge
tonight of course it was a very an
homage did they did they steal it from
Poltergeist they put a camcorder on an
oscillating fan and so the oscillating
fan that goes here and you don't see
nothing goes back the other way and then
you come back and oh my God the kitchen
what happened it's great yeah yeah I
don't want to pass this up real quick
because we did talk about Poltergeist
which isn't on here it's not the one I
put on my list but I also really
appreciate the Revenge of gentrification
uh sort of theme that is at the bottom a
lot of these a lot of these it's like no
like there's just certain things about
horror films that are tropian that are
awful but any horror movie where the
black person is or like the people of
color the ones be like y'all need to go
the indigenous folks The Shining was
another where they talked about the
indigenous community that yeah like
warning these nice meaning Caucasian
leave or you literally built it on our
land it's so funny so what's your scary
movie what are you taking out it as well
yeah I would definitely take out it I
would honestly also take out either
Insidious or uh Sinister I think both of
them are great but I feel like it's two
songs in the same key
um and I would definitely take out the
Ring The Ring is not oh no I would take
out the room Jaclyn I would take out the
ring isn't that the original
it's the Remake and it's still so good
well there's been two ring remix this is
this is Naomi Watts 2002 this is the
direct remake of the Japanese film
Rangoon not the ring remake right right
in like 2017 or whatever where it's like
getting at you through YouTube
I just got to say there was nothing
really like this this was so like
traumatizing to me I did see it in a
theater I was either in middle school or
high school it was like the the video
itself the default like their faces once
they had seen after their seven days the
her obviously coming out of the TV the
video it's the video itself was
terrifying
the horse running off the horse running
off of the boat felt bad about them the
fly when she when she likes when she
like freezes it and she's like trying to
move the frame oh my gosh I could talk
about this movie forever but also I want
to talk about our traumatizing things
that happened when we were young well I
had to pick my movie though let me just
pick my movie I'm adding in oh this is
not what I'm adding in I'm just want I
just needed to to defend it no look I
don't hate the ring I do like it it's
just it was fun it was fine I'm not
trying to pretend I really liked ringu I
liked ringu it's a different type okay
it was very different it feels like
Jaclyn's trying to not think about the
ring feels like you're trying to repress
this it's not repressing it was scary it
just when you know the other beats of
the other movie and you saw this one
second to my personal opinion I think I
should have saw The Ring first I'll go
to a different movie and as far as me
being scared by it now the movies that I
would say though to add back in here
would actually be final destination the
first one that's great Final Destination
the first one and or audition which is
body horror but yeah oh my God Japanese
horror they know how to torture people
that is the only thing I will say like
that will be stuff you will have images
that you will think about because that's
to me what scary is any movie can scare
me for the hour and a half or two hours
that we're sitting in the theater the
movies that I think of as the most
scariest are the ones that will
literally like shake me up into a
Daydream to be like oh what happened oh
this is not coming to me that is a real
scary movie that's the thing about for
whatever reason that the ring did to me
and it's not just because I was a big
fan of running movies and watched a lot
of VHS tapes there was just something
about the ring that just got into my
skin I was like you I saw it in the
theater I was in college my sister and I
went were big horror movie fans and we
saw it midday but you know when you walk
into a theater and it's like overcast
it's like 4 P.M and you're like okay I
can handle this movie now then you walk
out and the sun's gone down and now it's
just dark and you're like oh God this is
gonna be a long night isn't it that's
the feeling I had with the ring you had
some childhood trauma to get off your
chest oh no I was just gonna say that I
had like a disposable camera back then
that's what we used to do as friends and
so my mom had picked up pictures for me
and I asked her if she had them and I
was wearing these like white tennis
shoes as you did back then and
um or now no I just I just mean like
those chunky ones you know and the flare
the flash of it had smeared my face in
like multiple pictures oh no and so I
was just I just like lost it and my mom
thought it was so funny
that this had happened to me from like
this Costco like photos or whatever that
she had picked up I hope it was just the
shoes yeah no it would but yeah they had
like smeared multiple pictures of my
face
I am alive now unless this is dream
world Danny and I mean according to the
Nobel prize winning physicist this year
maybe not this could all be a simulation
okay this is I I like to break down
horror movies by sort of the sub genre
that they are because the the other
movie that I'm thinking even more so
than it that I would take out just
because at least I can really enjoy it I
just don't see a whole lot of redeeming
value other than the movies it inspired
to the Texas Chainsaw Massacre it came
out in 74 it's an independent film I
appreciate all that stuff it just never
really got me anyway other than this is
gross and I feel weird watching it
you're from Texas Danny I don't know
different feeling on the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre but that's one of these like
slasher sort of serial killer movies
which I think are cool and they get
under my skin but not as much as the
demon movies The Possession movies the
psychological horror movies like The
Exorcist that's why I think the Exorcist
is still a worthy number one is because
regardless of how you think the the
makeup and the Practical effects
translate to modern day I think it still
holds up pretty well but it's just the
fact that this little girl did nothing
wrong she just was in the wrong place
and there was a demon that was just like
Captain howdy is like I'm getting into
this and now we gotta do deal with it
and it just yeah the boogeyman of Jason
or Freddy or a Leatherface any of those
they're just easier to compartmentalize
in your mind of like of course this
person is not going to become down the
street hunting for me like that's much
easier but who knows what freaky Spirits
are out there and if you're a person
that honestly believes in that type of
energy obviously it's much more yeah
like honestly I fear more for Tom
Brady's current situation having angered
a witch than I ever would that Jason or
Freddie are coming for me not hilarious
that is facts have you seen that man you
watched in this past weekend does he
look like Tom Brady somebody said that
they were looking at a press conference
of Tom Brady and that and I wish I could
give them credit but they said that Tom
Brady now looks like Mark Wahlberg
playing already I sent that to you yeah
you said that to me where it where like
Tom Brady has to has to like save the
world and he's played by Mark Wahlberg
it's not inaccurate no and I will say
this too it's like I that to me is
terrifying fine like putting the wrong
energy to the wrong person and having it
come back to you threefold the things
about the craft and all of that like
that was not a necessarily scary movie
watching it it's just a teen sort of you
know Thriller but that idea any movies
that tap into that they're coming for me
but the craft is one of those sort of
Gateway Movies yeah that we talked about
earlier where like if you see the craft
and you're and you're a kid you kind of
get inspired by it and you want to
investigate more of this stuff and then
that leads you down the pathway of
getting to scarier movies like The Witch
is another one yeah I would put in the
top ten but it's not like it's not a lot
of jump scares in that movie so Danny is
like a writer as somebody who acts in
these sort of things what is it about
those creepy crawly movies that don't
necessarily try to get you every five
minutes they just build this sort of
fear and this momentum and this tension
throughout the runtime I think something
that what Jacqueline was saying of it
being psychological and something that's
completely out of your control because
when I look at slasher movies which I
love I love slasher movies Halloween is
one of my favorite movies of all time as
you said there's so many copy cuts that
came after that it was really
groundbreaking also for the lack of
blood that they had but it still makes
you feel like there's there's so much
Gore happening
um but humans you can kill humans I know
I'd live I live and know humans we know
human nature
you could kill a person with a plastic
bag I'm sorry you could yeah if you if
you wanted a bit of water two inches of
water there you go there you go you know
you accidentally hit him on the head and
the wrong nerve they're gone yeah that's
it and so I have some pretty good
message here we're women we have to know
these things we have to know these
things that's why I'm saying folks and
also Michael who I love who who seems to
be you know Invincible moving a little
slow this last movie moving a little
slow so you know father time never
exactly Usain Bolt when it came to
athleticism I mean Michael's just
Slumber
people think he's moving faster okay the
music okay I'm just saying he was a
little hunched and I love him anyways
but like humans are humans you can kill
whereas ghosts demons and the fact that
they can
um look like your loved ones I think is
a terrifying thing the fact that they
can get in your head right that's what
that that's what Pazuzu did in The
Exorcist is when she's messing with
Father Charis and she turns into his mom
also it follows it follows a great one
yeah yeah it's actually I'm glad you
bring up it follows because that was a
brilliant horror movie I'm slightly
Disturbed that they've made that movie
give us the reason to keep that
filmmaker making other movies which I
don't think have lived up to that first
one but I I appreciate his effort on
that first one because it was so
groundbreaking and it was just a
completely different look and there's
other films that I feel I would put in
there I would put Cabin in the Woods
because for the first half of cab in the
woods I was in that as a horror movie
and everything it was about and it just
became even more brilliant when Drew
took it to where he ended up taking it
Cabin in the Woods is one that I think
deserves recognition not because because
it is not one of the scariest movies
I've ever seen it built some nice
tension but that's not what it's trying
to do I think that anybody who
appreciates a list like the one we're
talking about today has to give a tip of
the cap to Cabin in the Woods just
because of it it knows what it is so
well and it and it and it had fun with
us in the same way that I think in a
slightly scarier vein Wes Craven's New
Nightmare did because we've talked about
this on the show recently where yeah The
Nightmare on Elm Street lineage was this
one thing where Freddy Krueger and then
Wes Craven does this movie that's like
oh okay we're gonna act like those
movies exist in the world and now the
real Freddy Krueger is out and it's like
what the hell is going on for all the
Freddy fans that appreciated the ride
that Freddie was on from slasher to
stand up comedian it was nice that he
got to get back to his Kruger Roots
there yeah I also want to add this too
we have a great video on Rotten Tomatoes
talking about Scare Tactics and how
audiences have learned to be scared
differently and the thing that was so
incredible about that is for every time
you get an audience to jump or Scare for
anything in it because horror fans
understand that lexicon and because the
language continues the next time you do
it you have to subvert it it's sort of
the same reason why when you have
comedians coming back doing old Seinfeld
type bits people are like this feels
like stale comedy you have to subvert
the established thing and it's one of
the cool things about horror is it's an
it's a genre that influences itself much
more than all the other ones like like
comedy and horror they really need a
space yes for how we twist and turn and
pull through and I think it's
interesting looking at something like
romantic comedies right now I think
horror had that moment a few years ago
where it was getting stale with the
current subversion and now people are
ready for either the return to the
traditional or a new subversion of that
and so it's interesting comedy and
horror go hand in hand because you can't
the audience cannot be ahead of the joke
yeah the audience cannot be ahead of the
scare and that's why you have so many
comedy people in horror like Jordan
Peele you have Danny McBride doing the
Halloween movies you have um yeah we
it's uh you can't the audience cannot be
ahead of you and that's why up is harder
than being a musician wow oh wow they
could go back to their same Journey
doesn't hasn't had to write a new song
in 40 years and they can still headline
stadiums I gotta write new crap every
time I get up there same thing with a
horror movie you can't repeat the scare
unless you're doing it a decade later
and it's like an homage to something
right but if we're talking about the
specific scariest scenes in a movie you
take all the horror movies you've ever
seen what is the moment what is what is
that one part that still gets you that
you're just watching with with your eyes
through your hands your sleep with one
eye open that night all the lights on
what's the scariest horror scene for
Danny Fernandez so this is the movie
that I would have to add into this top
10 list and it's Blair Witch Project I
have no idea how the Blair Witch didn't
end up on here it is one of the most
terrifying movies I mean and again we're
talking about like practical and
something that you're not even really
seeing and you you feel that's the whole
thing though is you fill in that with
your own your mind can make up more
infinitely more terrifying things and so
the final scene that everyone knows what
I'm talking about is one of the most
terrifying scenes in cinema because we
see dude and he's in the basement of the
Blair witch's pad it's just the worst
episode of MTV watch it on YouTube even
me watching it in broad daylight with
the sun fully out on YouTube on my
little phone is like listening to her
screeching yeah he's just standing in
the corner and the way he's standing
it's like you did something bad that day
Junior yeah
laughs
I think I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention Hitchcock in this just because
he was the king of scares and obviously
the shower scene has become what it is
but you have to remember people stopped
bathing after seeing that movie because
that was the most familiar thing you
could do at that time and he made it
terrifying still to this day that I
don't walk into any bathroom at like any
place I'm not familiar with but like
punching the the shower curtain but I
think the scene for me and this is just
as a black person watching this movie
but I think a lot of black people can
say this and Night of the Living Dead
when he is walking out and he sees those
men coming towards him I personally said
this is the scariest moment for this
character because I just knew what was
going to happen in that moment and every
black person watching that movie knew
what was going to happen to him in that
moment it was not the zombies white men
with guns seeing him in that moment you
just knew he was gonna die because of
everything that had happened before that
you were so scared and terrified for him
and you still knew the inevitability of
it it's just yeah the thing about George
Romero's movie anyway is that it's such
a Scary Night of the Living Dead is a
terrifying concept regardless of who you
cast and in the fact that it was the
first horror film to feature a black
lead in prominence like that I mean it
was really one of the first movies that
was made for a mainstream audience this
is coming on the heels of the Civil
Rights Movement so to have that film
come out in 1968 it 68 Goodyear for
horror because he also had Rosemary's
Baby that year yes another terrifying
one basically another familiar thing
making women at that time who stole like
purpose in life was child rearing and to
make that the most terrifying thing that
they can do sis no and speaking of child
rearing my scariest scene I have two of
them because I'm a huge fan of this
stuff number two on our list is
hereditary oh yeah and the scene where
the poor girl this is I let Molly the
Wonder Dog put her head out the window
because she loves feeling the wind wow
but I know what a comparison hey that's
the closest that I'm ever gonna be to
being either an older brother of a young
girl or a father or anything like that
the the poor girl she's she's not
feeling well we're trying to get her to
the hospital she puts her head out the
window the wrong time conk is All I'm
gonna say the other one that I have
involves ahead as well but it's sort of
playing off of the classic scare from
Halloween where Laurie looks out the
window and she sees Michael Myers
hanging out by the laundry line right
and then you look back and you don't see
that person anymore I love those kind of
scares right you call them jump scares
whatever you want James Juan's great at
him there's a bunch of filmmakers that
really knock it out of the park but the
strangers is is my other scene and it's
not anything too deep in the movie it's
just that first shot where you see live
and Scott and they're just kind of
trying to hey did you hear something you
hear something and then in the
background you just see this head in a
burlap sack look in and then look back
out whoo
Airbnb look out look out that's all I'm
saying Barbarian another great one up
there so uh what did I remind you of who
was the first jump scare oh the first
jumps the very first jump scare
um older than you think was probably I
mean I would say something in like a uh
like a Frankenstein even even a
nosferata too getting warmer okay Bride
of Frankenstein no
oh I don't
um right universe is it like a werewolf
and it's had a recent remake
The Wolfman oh
Phantom of the Opera
Phantom of the Opera is the original
jump scare when the girl comes and
removes his mask and it was the very
first one and it was back in the you
know Universal dark monster days because
that was the very first dark monster was
the Phantom of the Opera Christine
exactly
um who's the uh who's the Hard director
that you got that y'all look at and
you're like this is I'll see anything
this person puts out I think Jordan
Peele recently on a lot of people's list
you go back to the classic like
Hitchcock you and I think we're both
talking about psycho because we both saw
it recently yeah and the shower scene
the thing I'll put up there though is
not not just the thing which is a great
movie with John Carpenter but people
don't consider this a horror movie I
think it's just transcended into
all-time Blockbuster classic
in the same way that psycho scared the
crap out of everybody from ever getting
a shower again Jaws had an effect on
folks Fair jaws and when I was a kid
going to video update Jaws was in the
horror section and I think that's
warranted yeah I don't disagree
um what do you have Professor the
filmmaker filmmaker where you're like
I'm down with this whole filmography I
have to do carpenter I feel like you
have to you know what's really funny is
um I did a a little poll on my Twitter
of like the what is the scariest movie
like what it has to be on your list and
so many people aside from The Exorcist
which I think is Iconic that both of
these came out decades ago and are still
beating you know to some extent uh with
their practical effects
um is the thing everybody said the thing
that was so many prize not on that on
there yeah the thing it's weird because
the thing and alien I think is another
one where maybe they got a little too
sci-fi and people consider them that now
but the thing is great because it's just
like wait are you really damn Annie are
you really Jacqueline or is there
something else going on in there yeah no
I like again Invasion of the Body
Snatchers any of
Friend or Foe you can't believe your
eyes type movies again it's something
where what you consider due north just
gets completely I think shifted no
matter what I don't know who like my
favorite like series of directors is no
matter what but I will say anytime
Guillermo del Toro is touching monsters
right in there you know what I mean like
I'm not saying that every single one but
even something like shape of water which
is also Monster Tale and and Hellboy
it's just if this man is dealing with
what I know to be his most prized form
of filmmaking meaning the monster movies
he's and that's even scary stories in
the dark he did that really well you
know that's not my type of horror
necessarily he did that one very very
well you know something is I was
listening to Michael jokino who just did
uh werewolf by night and he said that he
I think it's something about why I'm
going back to the composer filmmaker
like tie-in is that he actually as they
were doing the dailies like he would he
would compose the music and play it for
the the actors the next day and I'm like
what a gift what a gift to hear in your
head what is what your character is
going what's going to be playing over
the terrifying thoughts of your
character and so that's why I think with
Carpenter it's just so like why are you
giggling because I hear that and I'm
like John Carpenter
but it's great but but my question is
this is that in giacino's pay or is that
like extra because you're there every
day and you're composing you're writing
new music he couldn't not do it he
couldn't nothing like he couldn't not do
it he was he was watching the playback
and he was like I know exactly how this
is going to sound I can't believe it can
someone write I can't believe you just
said that John Carpenter's only like
those two no I'm saying that Carpenter
wrote it in advance
Carpenter in concert he's amazing okay
Escape From New York I feel the shade I
I felt you honestly on this platform for
folks that don't know um we we always be
kind to John Carpenter because uh one
morning a few years ago we accidentally
killed him and he's still very much
alive okay oh really yeah
it was like we actually said it was just
like a wrong quote on a social post but
then we did a great article on Rotten
Tomatoes where we were like so we killed
John Carpenter but we called to
apologize and we wrote a great paper
about it it wasn't a a talent knock at
John Carpenter's just that he's
directing Halloween so he's there anyway
every day Michael giacchino is a
composer who directed and so I'm just
wondering it's like I don't know I I
would need a little bit okay you brought
up jaws and it has that done yeah that's
half that's I would say that's half of
why that was so iconic I would say it's
70. then the music the music makes a lot
of these Horrors I'm not saying it
doesn't I just want payment for my work
Michael Jackson
it's like Ricky Gervais because I
actually remember interviewing Steven
Merchant and he talked about this when
Rick your vase did the office the reason
why Steven Merchant started guest
starring was like because we both
created the show we both wrote on the
show he got an extra check and he was
like I'm gonna go and do another one and
so like of course Michael gets an extra
job of course okay what is the best what
is the best horror movie score so Jaws
is it Halloween I gotta go with
um it follows soundtrack so great it was
like my number two most listened to of
any music on Spotify
I can't picture there's like a bass line
that's kind of creepy in it right let's
see when somebody appears thank you for
that you were like one of my number one
listen to artists okay all right I'm
gonna do Silence of the Lambs I love
that score I believe that's Thomas
corner I like what Friday the 13th does
James Horner I like this also The
Shining sorry I gotta throw that out
there too the beginning of that Sean is
a good one shining is amazing I am gonna
take the music from psycho great because
it's it takes you on the ride the whole
way not just with the shower scene but
with Marion's journey and there like it
gets tense and she's she's she's
committing basically a crime here across
state lines and you just you feel
nervous for her and for what the rest of
this movie has the entire time but then
I'll also say going back to our show a
few weeks ago remember I'm straight for
me the one two Freddy's coming for you
yeah just chef's kiss
I would also just to put on this list
because this past weekend at Middleburg
I sat down with Michael Ables who won
this year's award for best composer and
anybody who could make I got five on it
be that effort yeah great got my money
sir like legit he did us which I think
is like a lot of these composers
um when you look at it in a classical
music sense because folks that don't
know I'm a classical music Stan it's not
complex
composing it's not complex musicality in
fact it's quite simple musicality and
most of them are borrowing from the
Masters anyway like uh Empire Strikes
Back James he just stole that from
somebody else but what is interesting is
how they use Tempo and syncopation to
add scares and us is a perfect example
of that they're just like huge violin
like like um like leaps and and
intervals that really wake you up and
they make you feel like something is
coming outside and it's so off-putting
yeah there's the use of Music in in Drag
Me to Hell really gets me to it Sam
Ramey's another guy you should probably
bring up just because of the Evil Dead
franchise but Drag Me to Hell is a scary
ass movie it's fun it's pulpy but the
music in that it's there's some sort of
instrument that feels like turn of the
century 18 to 1900s and I don't know if
it's like an out-of-tune fiddle or like
an Old Violin or something but it just
sounds creepy yeah what is the start
they do do that I mean luckily in the
award space I get to talk to some of
these composers and they do everything I
mean Robert Edgar's got for the which
old period music uh impossible
instruments like their version of what a
guitar was at that time their version of
what an organ was at that time like even
like something that's not a horror movie
but like the sections the secession
theme is played on an Out Of Tune Piano
because it's supposed to be this musical
music where things are just a little bit
dissonant it's beautiful and it's pretty
and it's elevated but no it scares the
crap out of me every week and and when
you watch the beginning of succession
the old like the old footage I feel like
I'm watching Sinister that's and that
was his intention is because he wanted
you to see something and feel it
picturesque because the melody is
actually an incredible there's a great
video where he breaks it down as well
it's really melodic Melody except for
this one little D this one little D
that's just like an off-putting key that
doesn't belong there and playing it on
an auto-tune 18th century piano you
really feel the legacy of hate that this
Empire is built on I'm looking at some
of these other horror movies that have
come out recently and so I'm going to
Rattle off a few that have come out in
the last couple years y'all tell me if
they have any shot of getting into your
top ten the babadook yeah maybe from
that's from 2014 Duke is great I don't
know if it's in the scariest I've never
really scary iconic as much as I just
enjoyed watching iconic but I'd say
iconic okay here's a good one Dr sleep
playing off of The Shining no not on
your life sorry Ewan I appreciated you
as a person I thought it was a great
movie I just didn't think it was as
scary I'm glad you did
The Shining sequence in Ready Player One
because you go back to the Overlook
Hotel and you're just existing there for
like because Spielberg loves that movie
and he loves Kubrick he loves Kubrick
that's for sure so getting to back to go
to The Shining is another one ah here's
a good one midsomar no absolutely
positively not uh you know yeah I agree
you know I have such a let me just put
it out here still think it's trash told
him to in that day William Jackson
Harper sir I'm so glad you have found
better
oh wow what I have to say is I have such
um a visceral reaction to that film and
so then I think it's done its job I do
have to say that there are a couple of
movies when people like I hate this
movie and I'm like okay then maybe it
has done its job no and so I feel that
way just personally and my friends are
like why why do you hate it so much why
is it so traumatizing to you I'm like I
never want to see that movie again and
therefore you did a good job yeah I'm
not gonna anyway say that Ari did not
achieve his goal in making me disgusted
by the entire property like he
definitely that's what he's going about
and if you know his like more extended
shorts filmography you will know that
like that level of shock and discuss is
something that he loves to lean into
um
welcome to the Johnsons I think is it
called like check out that short if you
want to hear what I'm saying um is that
different from Johnson Family Vacation
and in so many ways trust me in so many
ways on a road trip but I will say this
um Florence is incredible it incredible
I just think the movie is not near as
smart as it thinks it is and I think
it's playing with some pretty pedestrian
themes and I think all for all the
visual spectacularness of it it is a
pretty Hollow effort those two old
people they get to the Top of the Rock
and it's like they're going well for you
not gonna say that it doesn't have
cinematic moments and that certain
people will enjoy it but if anybody
wants to do a Rotten Tomatoes wrong
episode on mid-summar I will come with
my thoughts uh what are you working on
right now working all the kids follow
you all that good stuff you can follow
me at Ms Danny Fernandez it's
msda-n-i-f-e-r-n-a-n-d-e-z and Mark you
are actually in I shot my first uh
horror film that's going to be going to
uh Festival well not like the first one
that I've written that I also got to be
in and our friend uh Robert Butler
directed and Mark uh it's an office
worker was uh in it I was in the
background and I was the perfect office
worker because I was in character that
day because we shot my scenes on a
Sunday in the fall and so every chance I
got I had my my football
than you and so and so it was kind of
like a normal office worker during March
Madness so I really got into character
yeah for you my dear friend Danny
Fernandez so follow her at Miss Danny
Fernandez on all social media platforms
uh we've talked about a crap ton of
scary movies today do you have a movie
recommendation for everybody that they
need to see either during Halloween or a
streaming show or anything else you can
get away from the scares here if you
want to oh my gosh yeah uh we've been
watching
scary I have to go when I'm well
speaking of going from Comedy into
horror-esque one of my favorite shows uh
is Severance and so it's so great if you
haven't watched yet and you're in for a
spooky treat it definitely has it's a
psychological Thriller type um so that's
Ben Stiller and Adam Scott yeah uh so
two comedy people who uh freaking you
out so I love Severance I'm allocated a
conversation with him and on top of
being the nicest guy just having him who
you think is this like very unassuming
guy talk about how terrifying the
concept of severance is because it is so
terrifying and just how yeah what they
had to sort of commit to it's I I dig
that recognition I love that show hang
in there for the whole first episode by
the end of the first episode I promise
you'll be hooked um that is Danny
Fernandez Our Guest here today on the
scariest movies of all time for
Jacqueline Coley I am really Mark Ellis
I'm in Seattle this weekend one show
only you can get tickets at
markellis.live uh it's Friday night
October 28th and then the special is
taping December 3rd right here in Los
Angeles tickets at my website as well
for Jacqueline for the whole team here
we did it wait yes and then we have next
week next week yeah it's so great guys
um the book that this podcast was made
off of it only took us almost 125
episodes to do an episode on it the
cover of a book Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
as Step Brothers it is Will Ferrell and
John C Reilly jumping into the pool and
we're gonna do that it's like when Jack
and I saw the Meg and we looked at each
other and we said do we just become best
friends yes
[Music]